[Music]
what's up mkbhd here
and these are some of the most hyped
new pieces of tech in a while these are
the nothing
year one earbuds and you can already see
at first glance there's already some
pretty unique things
about them so you might have followed
the whole startup story of this new
company
founded by carl pay former founder of
oneplus
and now who's turning into like a
mastermind or generating hype
i have chosen to ignore all of the hype
and the slow burn of headlines about
this for the past couple months
because you know expectations are the
thief of joy why get yourself psyched
out
when it's only the product itself that
actually matters right so now we have
the product
it's here it's a pair of 99 dollar
wireless earbuds
with active noise cancellation and
wireless charging
now i got these about four days ago by
the time you're watching this
took them out of the very nicely
packaged box listened to a lot of music
on them
worked out in them really put them
through their paces and i gotta say
they're really not bad from all that
though the best part of these headphones
easy is a hundred percent this design so
nothing partnered with this swedish
company called teenage engineering
to design this transparent set of
headphones and right off the bat
that's actually a bigger deal than most
people realize in a product like this
not only because it looks cool you know
you get your black and white
and clear aesthetic and you get to add
some nice printed text on the inside it
looks cool
these headphones definitely look sweet i
love what they've done
with this unique design but also a lot
of the places
inside earbuds where you can normally be
sloppy you have to spend
more time on to actually make it neat
because people will see it
so with battery and pcb placement and
the microphones
and the glue oh god especially all the
glue
it never looks this neat and trim inside
of most other earbuds so i know we don't
do this all the time but if you were to
cut open
take anything some some air pods or a
pair of galaxy buds or sonys or whatever
you want
you would see that to hold these pieces
together there's glue
on the inside and that glue doesn't have
to be
nearly as neat it doesn't have to be
pretty at all the wires don't have to be
tucked away in any certain way
it just all kind of has to be in the
bulb
and work but here i mean there's seams
there's glue there's batteries
everything is so trim and so neat so the
fact that these are clear
and still look good is pretty impressive
they clearly had to focus a lot on it
and i'd say it's worth it i think they
look dope now the overall shape is still
pretty familiar like they look
basically like airpods pro but with a
smaller rectangular sort of stem
and they're very comfortable with the
huge bonus of being
super light 4.7 grams per ear
so it really does feel easy to leave
them in for long periods of time
and forget about them the only funny
thing is i don't know if anyone else
remembers the original
nothing teaser image that looked like
totally transparent
you know maybe they got a little too
ambitious back then because these
look nothing like that nothing
uh but that just is another reason not
to pay too much attention to all the
hype and
get so excited when it's not even gonna
look like that in the first place but
still looks cool anyway the case here
that it comes with
is also partially clear
it's a little big but it also does have
a couple features that are also pretty
nice to see in this price range so you
can see it's this clamshell style
the earbuds fit in at the corners with
magnets
and you've got a matching red dot for
the right earbud which also has a red
dot in it
but i like how these snap into place the
magnets are good and you can literally
see them in the stems so that's cool
and then the case has a usbc port which
is nice but it also supports qi wireless
charging and i noticed the led light
indicator that's just
telling you whether or not it's on the
charger is super
super responsive i've never seen
anything indicate
wireless charging this fast before so
that's pretty cool
and then in the middle when it's closed
there's this big
dimple that's partially a great way to
hold the earbuds firmly in place in the
case but it also doubles
as a nice fidget spinner if you
yeah maybe not um but bottom line is
this is it's a plastic case like any
normal one but
it is kind of big still it's definitely
not as pocketable
as something like you know galaxy buds
plus
or pixel buds a series which are both at
this price range
but they kept the semi-transparent thing
going which is clearly very important to
them
even though it probably doesn't look
great if it ever cracks or scratches but
speaking of priorities
how do they sound well again context
they sound pretty good not amazing
the the more expensive earbuds do sound
better but having active noise
cancellation at this price
is pretty clutch so basically with the
silicon tips and the light weight
i was actually very happy with how
comfortable these are with the passive
seals
but these 11.6 millimeter drivers
definitely sound
much better with noise cancellation on
where it really brings in much more bass
and the full sound stage
but basically they sound like an average
pair of
casual 100 earbuds a bit of a v-shaped
frequency response
the highest highs are a little bit tinny
and the bass is
big and full but not super punchy and
there's plenty of volume you can sit
around half volume maybe 60
and be totally happy there's actually
two levels of noise cancellation
light and maximum not really feeling a
big difference between the two when i
switch
but on maximum they feel about half as
strong
as airpods pro maybe two-thirds as
strong really
they're best with low frequency white
noise like air conditioning
or road noise if you're in a car or
something like that but it did still let
some of the higher frequency like hissy
sort of stuff through a little bit now
again i'm comparing these to airpods pro
because that's what i know best but keep
in mind those are
much much more expensive headphones like
three times the price
so that's not a criticism that's just
context
these are still very good i still think
i would fly with these they're also ipx4
splash resistant so they survived a
workout
and you definitely could get rained on
no problem probably won't have to worry
about these
and they are touch controls on the stems
of the buds that work just as well when
sweaty as dry so there's a long press to
switch between
noise cancellation modes and you can
swipe up and down
on the stems to change volume plus
different amounts of taps for playback
controls there is a little bit of a
learning curve with the swipes you have
to really make it like an
obvious full-size swipe to get it to
change volume but once you learn that
it's no problem and then battery life is
okay it's about four hours with anc on a
little bit longer with it off
five to six hours total and then you can
of course get up to a full
24 to 34 in the case
but i was hoping it'll be a bit longer i
guess the problem is i'm
i'm so calibrated to some of the others
if you've played with galaxy buds plus
you can get like 10 hours out of those
things
but i suspect matching that in this like
transparent form factor where you can
see
everything would have probably been
impossible now there is an ear one
app for ios and android that ties it all
together
it's pretty simple it doesn't do a whole
lot but it does let you control the
sound feature
and touch controls so in sound you can
switch between
cancellation strength or to a
transparency mode that's pretty decent
love to see it and there's also an
equalizer toggle down here at the bottom
that i thought was going to give me like
a whole graph
to really fine-tune these things but
it's really just a more treble
or more bass button or a voice mode that
just nukes all the frequencies outside
of a normal voice for phone calls
then in the touch section you can
customize what a triple tap
or a long hold does on each of these
earbuds independently
so i have triple tap on the left earbud
to go back a song and triple tap
on the right earbud to go to the next
song now i did have some weird
connection issues i gotta say
um i would get the right earbud to
connect but the left
wouldn't which is like a weird problem
you usually only see
in some of the really cheapest earbuds
out there
but i am testing this on pre-release
software and i'm hoping that by the time
this is public this is fixed and this
isn't a problem because that would be a
bummer if it was
um but that that's something i should
mention is if you're using an
app and it's connecting everything and
giving you all your features you want it
to work well all the time for the
limited amount of things it actually
does there's also a dark theme
in this app and a find my earbuds
feature that just blasts this ringing
sound from the earbuds at max volume
which is very high so you can find them
if they're across the room or in a car
or on a couch or something but if you
put this
all together i give the looks
an a maybe a plus uh the sound
a b and the features a
b plus you know i was hope maybe you
know an a would have been
if you could have an eq and really
adjust and dial in
some of those frequencies you want to
adjust and also i was hoping i'd be able
to toggle
the assistant with a long hold but
that's not available in the settings so
there's a couple extra things i'd wanted
to do but
generally as far as a combination of
things that this
does for 99 bucks it's pretty good so
assuming you didn't fall for the hype
and think these were going to like beat
some of the 300
flagship wireless earbuds out there
these these don't sound as good these
don't have
as good noise cancellation but that's a
very high bar
to clear and this is a nice place for
them to sort of jump into the market
i like them honestly i think a lot of
people are going to get these just for
the really nice design
because they are really nice and i i
think that's something a lot of
companies also have realized
especially in the last decade or so like
there's a lot of wireless earbuds out
there
most people at this price range aren't
buying them
for the sound quality only they're
buying them
because of the set of features and then
how they look and if they happen to
sound good that's fine and so these
have a pretty good set of features and
look great so they're going to do well
well done as for the rest of the hype
well that was just much to do about
nothing
thanks for watching catch you guys later
[Music]
peace